see i told you there's lots to pack in
this morning big day for hundreds of
thousands of gcse students today who get
their results soon the school's minister
on the show very shortly before that we
want to bring you some new pictures just
in and this is showing the devastation
caused by wildfires in algeria that have
now killed 65 people
28 soldiers trying to fight the flames
have also lost their lives jemima walker
reports
wild blazes and desperate attempts to
save their homes
these are the scenes in the tizi uzu
province of northern algeria as
wildfires carved through the forested
areas
dozens of people have already fallen
victim to the blaze resulting from
unprecedented temperatures
the fires have left animals and people
displaced
some feel like they're fighting an
impossible battle
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
foreign leaders have offered their help
the french president emmanuel macron
said france will send two water bombers
to the worst affected regions
despite tensions with morocco their king
has also offered firefighting equipment
in one incident 28 soldiers were killed
while protecting people's homes
algeria's president abdulmajid taboon
has declared three days of national
mourning
all government business has now been
suspended as the country tries to
prevent further tragedy
jewish
sky news
oh my goodness me is it down to climate
change we'll be talking about that in
more detail later on
in the program before that though half a
million students will receive their gcse
results today with grades being
determined by teachers again after
another year of exams being cancelled
because of the pandemic let's talk about
it in more detail our reporter sadia
chowdhury joining us from firth park
academy which is in sheffield good
morning to you there must be some
jangling nerves there this morning
good morning yeah the students haven't
arrived yet but remember this has been a
very difficult year for them many of
them would have had long absences from
their academic year so this year they're
being assessed only on the things that
they have been taught and they're going
to be assessed on multiple pieces of
work so they can really show what
they've achieved and for the teachers
they've had guidance this year in in
terms of how to make more you know
objective decisions and also those
results have been checked not just by
the head teachers here but also by the
exam board so lots going on here
you can see the preparations behind me
balloons as exam results are set to be
opened by students in the next few hours
we'll bring you all the reaction from
here in sheffield look forward to it
thanks very much indeed thanks a lot
well joining us now is the schools
minister nick give mr gibber a pleasure
to see this morning thanks for joining
us on the program hundreds of thousands
of uh teenagers receiving their gcse
results this morning your message to
those
who don't uh receive the increasingly
attainable higher grades
well my message to those young people is
there are lots of options available the
there's a helpline the national career
service helpline for them to that and to
to ring to find out and get advice for
what to do next but there are a lot of
options
for those that don't get the grades to
go on to do a levels or t levels are
there all kinds of different vocational
qualifications or apprenticeships
that that young people can consider they
can retake those gcses of course if they
wish to as well there's an autumn series
they can retake those exams in the
autumn uh if they wish to uh to take
them to take them and of course there's
an appeal process for young people who
feel that they've not been given the
right rate but today we should be
congratulating those hundreds of
thousands
of young people who have achieved so
much in very trying and difficult
circumstances over the last 18 months
and we should be paying tribute to all
those young people for what they've
achieved it's the culmination of not
just two years of the gcse course but 11
years of school education so
congratulations to everyone who's
receiving their grades today to enable
them to go on to the next phase of their
education whether that's t levels or a
levels or an apprenticeship and also
thank you to the teachers who've done a
magnificent job in administering the
teacher assessed grade system with all
the advice and guidance that they've had
from the exam boards and the and the
evidence that they've never been uh that
they have compiled to determine the
grades that have been awarded today okay
uh well given what we saw with the a
levels it looks as though the kids will
do very well 45
of a level results were either a or a
star this is going to have to be
looked at for next year isn't it because
you can't just have you know half of
kids getting a and a stars how do you
then differentiate between them going
forward is that something that's going
to have to be considered for next year
yes this this is an exceptional year uh
designed to to to make sure that despite
the pandemic and despite the fact that
we had to cancel exams because it
wouldn't have been fair for children
young people to sit exams and they've
had such different experiences of kovi
the different levels of self isolation
and so on so the teacher assessed grade
system is the best alternative to making
sure they can go on to the next phase of
their of their education or their
questions
but we have already with respect with
respect minister that's not my question
my question is not this year next year
you're going to have to refresh the
grading system for next year aren't you
yeah so we've already announced the the
the adjustments to the exams we expect
all young people to be taking exams uh
in 2022 but we'll be making adjustments
to those exams to reflect the fact that
this cohort will have had disruption to
their education as well and the
regulator off quo will be saying more
about the grading standard that will be
used
for those exams
in the autumn term
okay so just to clarify you will be
refreshing the grading system for next
year
no what i said was we'll be talking
about what the grading standard will be
for the 2022 exams we are looking also
in the longer term
about how to make sure that we get back
to the system we had before the pandemic
broke where we had year on year no grade
inflation and we want to get back to
that system
in the longer run but we have to make
sure when we do that that we are fair
between different year different cohorts
of the ones that took the exams in 2020
and 2021 and the ones the students are
taking the exams in the future is
fairness that lies at the heart of any
decision
any decisions about grading these are
very difficult decisions to make and we
will be doing so in conjunction uh with
the regulator with the exam board and
indeed with teachers and parents and
students up and down the country before
we come to firm decisions but but the
issue about the grading system is the
longer term sorry we only have a limited
amount of time minister as you know and
i've allowed you very full some answers
to the first two questions you're
talking about being fair uh private
school uh pupils grades far higher than
those from less uh privileged
backgrounds you've been schools
ministers since uh 2010
is it demoralizing for you with all the
work that you've done to close that
attainment gap to then see what's
happening
well we have closed retainment gap since
2010 by 13 percent in primary schools
and by nine percent and second up to the
beginning of the of the pandemic
independent schools are academically
selective by and large and they always
do get the higher higher share of top
grades and this year what we've seen is
that right across the school system
whatever kind of school uh the young
person goes to they have seen an
increase in those top grades and if you
look at the relative change in those top
grades independent schools have gone up
by about 15 percent
comprehensive have gone up by about 18
percent so
those top students are performing better
right across the board wherever whatever
type of school they go to but we are
determined as a government we have been
since 2010 to close that attainment gap
and that's what all our reforms have
been about the reforms to reading the
reforms to how you teach math the
changes to the curriculum in secondary
school the changes to the gcses and a
levels have all been about making sure
that every young person regardless of
their background gets the best possible
education okay minister university
students do you agree with your boss who
was on the show earlier in the week that
they should receive a refund if online
learning continues
well what we said is that there's there
are no covert reasons now for
for students not to receive face-to-face
uh education these are matters
ultimately for for universities but
there's certainly no covered reason why
students cannot
receive face-to-face education the
office for students the regulator does
monitor very closely the quality of
education
that students are receiving in our
universities and if students have
complaints they should of course
complain to the university and through
the complaints process okay my question
was should they receive a refund your
boss thinks they should do you agree
with him
well there can be that there are
students who have gone through that
complaints procedure who have then
received conversation from the
university but these are ultimately a
matter
of there are ultimately matters for the
university and we have a very powerful
regulator that gavin referred to i
understand all that i'm asking your
opinion do you agree with your boss that
kids who cannot have face-to-face
learning should get a refund
as i've said there is a procedure by
which they can get compensation
and that they need to go through the
complaints proceeding if the quality of
education they are receiving isn't of
the standard that is required by the
regulator okay so if that's the case and
lots of them do that who's going to pay
for the shortfall
well that would be the university sector
if they're not providing the quality of
education that the regulator requires of
them then of course the university
themselves will have to fund any
compensation payments made to to those
students but i am confident that we do
have very high quality education in our
universities we have a world-leading
university sector in this country which
we can be proud they have responded
extremely well
uh to increasing numbers of students
going to university we've seen a five
percent increase last year another five
percent increase in places this year we
have record numbers of young people
going to university and record numbers
of of young people from disadvantaged
backgrounds going to university so i
think we can be proud of our university
sector and what they're doing for young
people and what they're doing for our
country okay to that end do you agree
that universities should be paying
compensation for kids to defer for 12
months so like exeter university is
offering 10 grand for some kids to do
fair for a year
well every year there are a number of
students who do a small number of
students who defer and that's the same
this year at universities we've been
working very closely
with you so you're not answering any of
my questions this morning do you think
that universities should pay students to
defer for a year
yes they can do if they wish to but
these things are always optional
for students any student that achieves i
need it on that one i just want to ask
you about your boss now um kierstama has
called for him to be sacked why do you
think he should keep his job
because he's a very effective education
secretary i've worked with gavin
williamson for the last two years and he
has driven to make sure that no student
will suffer long-term damage to their
prospect as a consequence of the
pandemic he's driven to continue the
reform program in our education system
where we're seeing we up until covered
we saw that attainment gap close in
primary school and in secondary school
and he's driven to do more to make sure
we continue
to drive up standards in our education
system so that background does not
matter in terms of the opportunities
available for young people okay talk to
me about what's going on in berlin and a
british man arrested for spying uh
tobias elwood mp suggesting we need to
review the status of private security
personnel um do you agree
well i don't feel i'm able to talk about
this issue this is now subjecting the
government this morning uh police
investigation
you're here representing the government
this morning
yes i am and because this is a matter of
police investigation it would not be
appropriate for any minister to come on
your program and to discuss this
particular issue okay i wonder if you
think that you have a view on the fact
that we don't have a security minister
that post has been open for a month uh
we should be filling that shouldn't we
given stuff like this is happening
well again this is the matter for for
the prime minister and uh he makes these
appointments and i'm sure that these
things will happen in due course okay
i'm going to ask you about the gurkhas
then has anyone from the government
spoken with representatives from the
gurkhas that are on hunger strike just
on whitehall
there well we do take very seriously the
issue of the pensions for goku's the
gurkhas pension scheme we have increased
it between 10 and 25 since march 2019
added another 25 million pounds in terms
of providing health
for goku's in uh nepal
and you know ministers are of course in
touch with uh and will be in touch with
those people that are that are concerned
about the pensions for goku's the
gurkhas are a very important part of the
british army and we've always taken very
seriously uh the welfare and the
pensions of goku served in our in our
armed forces just to clarify you said
that ministers had been in touch with
them yeah
well i i'm not entirely sure who's met
who but i do know that we are always
keen to talk to people who are concerned
about the welfare of of of our of our
gurkha regiment and the and the uh and
the pensions arrangements for those for
those soldiers as i said we have been
we have increased the gurkhas pension
scheme uh in march 2019 to make sure
that we are providing
pensions for those uh for those uh
gurkhas who serve so well in our armed
forces indeed so 250 million quid for a
boat for ministers to travel around the
world that's what the prime minister is
proposing while these veterans are
starving themselves to death on the
streets of uh whitehall the optics are
not good are they whatever the rights
and wrongs
the government has to do something about
this
and that would be a matter for the mod
in terms of wanting to sell britain
abroad it is important we are a global
trading nation uh and we need to make
sure that we're doing everything to sell
british business abroad and that's the
purpose of of of of this of the kind of
projects that you're talking about
making sure that we are getting our
businesses exporting around the world
as we uh having left the european union
and that is what global britain is all
about okay quick thought before i let
you go your boss couldn't remember his a
level grades when he was asked earlier
on in the week can you remember
yours i can yes if you uh yes i can
remember them yes go on tell me
oh well i got four four grey days and i
was able to go on to the university that
i hope to go to and uh and and gavin
also was able to go to the university
that he uh wanted to go to and he was
very pleased by his results it's great
to talk to you thanks for taking the
time
thank you very much
uh some breaking news just reaching us
in the last few moments the office for
national statistics has published the
gdp figures for the second quarter of
2021 what are they what do they look
like our business correspondent helen
ann smith joining us now from outside
the treasury hello to you helen and tell
us
more good morning kay yeah that's right
uh quarter two figures for gross
domestic product essentially the value
of all products and services in the
economy it's one of the best barometers
we have to really take the temperature
of how the economy is doing and it grew
by 4.8
in the second quarter of this year now
that's not particularly surprising it's
roughly in line with what economists uh
predicted as well because you remember
of course those three months april may
and june were the months where we
started to reopen after that heavy
period of that third lockdown so we were
recovering from quite a low uh base uh
if you like uh so important to see there
roughly in line with what economists
expected but remember when it comes to
gdp gdp figures perspective and context
is absolutely everything and any normal
quarter in any normal year 4.8 would be
absolutely enormous but we're recovering
from that very very low base and of
course gdp has done very unusual things
over the last 18 months or so and we're
still 4.4 percent what we were on
pre-pandemic levels the chancellor will
certainly be concerned with making sure
that sustained throughout the summer
he's got some big spending commitments
to pay for as well so he'll certainly be
encouraged but challenges ahead for sure
okay for now thank you very much thanks
a lot obviously we'll be looking forward
to hearing from the chancellor himself
later on on the programme then at 20 to
9 we'll mark world elephant day by
crossing to a sanctuary in kenya to
discuss what is being done to protect
and preserve the earth's elephants
plus
louis pugh is back and he's taking on
his most challenging swim yet
find out what he's doing at 8 45
and then at 9 30 we'll speak to the
gurkha veteran who's continuing his
hunger strike outside downing street
[Music]
intelligence officials are continuing to
question a british man who worked at the
uk embassy in germany on suspicion of
spying for russia let's get more on that
now our correspondent alex rossi is in
berlin for us this morning hello to you
alex what more do we know
well the germans as you would imagine
kay are taking this extremely seriously
it went before an investigating judge at
the federal court of justice yesterday
the warrant for his continued detention
was approved and he remains in custody
where he is being questioned now he's
only been identified as david s we do
know his full name uh now but we won't
be
uh revealing that because of the strict
privacy laws here in germany and also
for legal reasons in the uk but it's our
understanding that he was a private
contractor he was working inside the
british embassy as a
security guard now we think that he uh
started according to the authorities
here or the allegation is that he
started working for the russians
sometime in november last year the
authorities say he was monitored he was
under surveillance for some time before
he was picked up and arrested on tuesday
at his apartment in
potsdam now his place of work here the
areas with which he worked in his
apartment has now been uh searched and
as i was saying he continues to be
questioned now this of course has
resonance for many people because of the
cold war and the alleged russian
involvement this place was known at the
time as the capital of spies germany was
divided this city was divided it was a
front line in the confrontation the
ideological confrontation between the
western camp and the soviets then of
course
nuclear weapons were pointed at each
other now you think things have changed
dramatically since then but perhaps not
the head of domestic intelligence here
in germany told the parliament last year
that the levels of espionage now in this
country are as high as the cold war
times
if not higher
okay alex for now thanks for the update
that story featuring on the front pages
of many of today's national newspapers
today let's start with the telegraph
should we it says the british person
arrested is strongly suspected of
working for the russians since last
november that's the way the telegraph is
seeing it what about the mirror they
have the same story russia spy
sold secrets
the mail understands the allegations
relate to the sharing of classified
terrorism documents
with the times adding that the material
relates to british activities not german
activities picture there of um
the duke of york arriving at balmoral
finally the financial times reports that
mi5 had been tracking the suspect for
many months
looking at some of the other stories
making news for you this morning and we
can tell you what's going on in
afghanistan american intelligence
officials say taliban fighters could
take control of the afghan capital kabul
within three months the group has
captured nine provincial capitals in
less than a week it's thought islamic
fighters now control around 65 percent
of the country
british scientists say they have
discovered more details on why some
people receiving the astrazeneca vaccine
develop blood clots a team from oxford
university hospital has concluded that
patients with very low platelets through
a condition called vit are most at risk
they say this type of reaction to the
astrazeneca vaccine remains very rare
new zealand will begin a gradual
re-opening of its borders early next
year the prime minister jacinda ardern
says restrictions will be phased out
with other countries graded low medium
or high risk new zealand closed its
borders to most foreign travel in march
of last year
britain's most notorious con man mark
aklum is about to be freed early from
prison but will have to live under tough
restrictions ordered by a judge the
serial fraudster must declare his
earnings business dealings and assets
close any foreign bank accounts stop
using false names and tell police of his
movements the curbs on his freedom come
in a rare serious crime prevention order
that will last for five years our crime
correspondent martin brunt reports
brought back to britain in handcuffs
comm man mark acklum was jailed for
nearly six years
now he's about to be released early on
licence
but a judge has ordered him to live
under severe restrictions for five years
aklam's been given a rare serious crime
prevention order
under the order he must reveal his
income savings businesses and assets
close any foreign bank accounts stop
using false names tell police where he's
living and if he plans to spend a night
away from home
akla met his victim carolyn woods in her
cotswolds boutique
she later wrote a book of their marriage
plans his lies and deceit and his theft
of all her money he always does what is
best for
for him so i don't think having a
serious crime prevention order out in
his name is is really materially going
to affect what he does unless he is
physically tagged or something like that
so uh you know we all know that he's a
flight risk and i'm sure he will only
comply with
whatever will make life easier for him
in the long run aklam has spent much of
his time here he tried and failed to
launch an appeal but he's due to be
freed in a fortnight
akron will have spent barely a third of
his sentence in prison but although
there's a detailed plan to monitor him
after his release his freedom could yet
be postponed
he's already a wanted man again in spain
the spanish are trying to extradite him
in this hearing in cartagena in 2015
he was jailed for three years for fraud
he was given temporary release and fled
abroad
he still has 18 months to serve
when you consider the criminality that
goes on in spain serious violence people
trafficking they're probably not going
to be overly keen to keep him in prison
for too long anyway so i'm pretty sure
he will find a way of talking his way
out for an early release the spanish
authorities are expected to launch a bid
for aklam's extradition soon
martin brunt sky news wiltshire
extreme weather is continuing to cause
problems across southern europe the
italian island of sicily has reported
what could be the highest temperature
ever seen in europe officials say they
recorded a high of 48.8 celsius
yesterday that's just under
120 degrees fahrenheit the reading still
has to be verified by the world
meteorological organization the italian
health ministry has issued a series of
red alerts for extreme heat across the
country today and tomorrow
let's look at the impact of climate
change on the planet top line of our
infographic here gives you an idea of
how the real-time power mix is blended
for you this morning 29
of renewables and you can see how much
warmer the earth is now than in 1880
that's the second line down
1.23 degrees hotter than it was in 1880
then the figure below that
uh shows how long scientists believe it
will take to reach the plus 1.5 degrees
celsius figure seen by many as a point
of no return for our planet 11 years is
what they are predicting and finally
that huge figure at the bottom the total
amount of co2 emissions in millions of
tons
meantime what's happening as far as the
weather is concerned today let's find
out for you should we here's nas good
morning nas
good morning uh well it isn't looking
too bad for many areas today we are
going to see lots of fine and dry
weather but for some there will be
blustery showers
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
good morning well on the face of it
today doesn't look too bad at all for
most places it's going to be a mainly
dry day with some good spells of
sunshine feeling quite warm in parts of
the southeast too but there will be this
approaching though that will bring some
blustery showers in fact across western
parts of ireland there's already
approaching showers there where it's
windy elsewhere it's a mainly dry and
fine start but not everywhere there's a
cloudy zone across parts of east anglia
down towards central and southwest and
parts of england with some patchy light
rain and drizzle elsewhere a few missed
and fog patches as well now going to
this afternoon that low will continue
its way eastwards pushing through
blustery showers across the island
northern ireland and the north and west
of scotland a few showers may also
affect eastern and southern parts of
scotland but i think across these areas
it won't be too bad most of england are
well also saying sunshine and dry
conditions but it will take some time
for central and southwestern areas to
brighten up later
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
as you head for heights take a look at
this the stunt woman has
stood on top of the world's tallest
building to promote the reopening of
international air travel american
skydiver nicole smith ludwig climbed to
the top
the 828 meter high burj khalifa in dubai
dressed as a member of the emirates
cabin crew and the airline said it asked
for real members of staff to take part
but decided
it was safer if they used an expert that
was her training for it
and then she actually
went ahead and stood right on the top of
that building my goodness me most
impressive now we're going to look ahead
this morning to gcse results after
another year of cancelled exams because
of the pandemic that to come
hello again everybody hundreds of
thousands of gcse students will open
their results this morning and there are
predictions grades could spike again
after no exams for a second year in a
row but where will the government go
from here after another year of grade
inflation this is what the school's
minister nick gibb told me a short while
ago
so we've already announced the the the
adjustments to the exams we expect all
young people to be taking exams uh in
2022 but we'll be making adjustments to
those exams to reflect the fact that
this cohort will have had disruption to
their education as well and the
regulator off quo will be saying more
about the grading standard that will be
used for those exams
in the autumn term
okay so just to clarify you will be
refreshing the grading system for next
year
no what i said was we'll be talking
about what the grading standard will be
for the 2022 exams we are looking also
in the longer term
about how to make sure that we get back
to the system we had before the pandemic
broke where we had year on year no great
inflation and we want to get back to
that system uh in the longer run but we
have to make sure when we do that that
we are fair between different year
different cohorts of the ones that took
the exams in 2020 and 2021 and the ones
the students are taking the exams in the
future is fairness that lies at the
heart of any decision uh any decisions
about grading these are very difficult
decisions to make
tamara's uh here i'm a bit confused
about what he's saying there tomorrow
can you clarify morning k so half a
million young people waiting for their
gcse results but all the discussion is
now on we expect them to be record high
numbers of top grades today possibly the
highest ever for gcses and how we then
row back to normal because as we saw
with a levels on tuesday now 45
of pupils getting a star or a's you
can't then go back to 25
next year because these are students who
will be competing with each other for
university places for jobs and so on
this is a project that will take years
and what nick gibb was saying was that
they're going to look at the content of
exams for next year and what students
will be graded on because it's probably
not going to be the same as pre-pandemic
they've still missed a lot of schooling
but in terms of the actual exam grade in
the longer term they're going to look at
that as well and there are understand
discussions going on in government about
whether we now move a levels
away from the a to e system towards
one to nine to have a bit of a reset in
the future perhaps even with gcse grades
now so many uh children are expected to
get a stars perhaps to add another one
they're already one to nine maybe out of
ten on as well all these things are
being discussed none of this is going to
happen next year next year grades will
be as they are this year if exams take
place normally but in the longer term
they are looking at a kind of a reset
because it's going to be so difficult to
get back up to before covid began yeah
exactly especially with 45 getting a and
a start nevertheless half a million kids
are getting their results this morning
best of luck and we have got our fingers
thanks very much tomorrow we have got
our fingers crossed for them of course
we'll be catching up with some of them
uh in just a short time right now though
let's get the view of kylie oppel she's
the principal of bristol hall academy in
oldbury in the uh she
he forgive me i'm so sorry uh and joins
us at knife hello to you i'm so sorry i
i didn't see you uh before i made that
assumption how are you this morning talk
to me about what you're expecting
good morning kate not a problem at all
it's uh great to be with you here this
morning we're excited everyone here at
bristol hall academy and across our
academy transformation trust can't wait
to welcome our students across those
gates again so they can open those
envelopes and look forward to their
destinations whether it be further
employment um training whether it's
further education we certainly look
forward to welcoming them this morning
indeed so how do you think they've how
do you think the kids are going to be
doing uh 45 percent a and a star in a
levels it does look as though we'll see
a similar uplift for the kids doing
their uh gcses i almost call them o
levels then
well here at bristol academy we've seen
a year-on-year rise in exam results
we're not um surprised by this we'll see
our students most importantly get the
results they rightfully deserve there's
been a stringent
process in place protocols have been
robust
standardization and moderation across
the piece not just by experts in our
classroom here at bristol hall but
across our academy transformation trust
and that's up and down this country has
made sure the students are getting those
qualifications and they're the
qualifications that they're rightly
deserve yeah um how do you answer the
charge of grade inflation because
teachers have been marking
well of course i've had to double check
all about policies to make sure that we
are marking and assessing appropriately
and as i said the standardization of
moderation has ensured that great
inflation is eradicated you've got
professionals in the classroom who are
making those decisions and that's the
most important thing so if we're seeing
a rise of five to six percent based on
results from previous years that's
something that we'd expect anymore and i
think it's also important to note that
we're not just talking about those top
grades here we're not just talking about
the nines and the eights we're talking
about those students who've worked
tirelessly hard throughout this
difficult year to make sure they pass
get that four get that five and of
course make sure most importantly that
they get the grades that allow them to
go into the next stage in their career
and do you feel that you've had enough
clarity from government on on what needs
or what needed to be done ahead of the
grading system this year
well there's been lots of information
that's come out to us at schools and
academies across this country and
naturally so that's been the environment
that we've all been working on but
rather than worry about it and start to
concern our parents and carers by coming
across as though we don't know quite
what to expect we've been clearing our
communication with everybody we've made
sure our students are aware of exactly
what it is that they're going to be
assessed on
making them feel prepared and i think
that's the most important things our
students our families our stakeholders
have been incredibly resilient and what
they needed from schools up and down
this country is to make sure that we
were there for them stalwarts throughout
this pandemic and now of course as we
said it culminates with this morning
with those students having those huge
smiles on their faces well hopefully
you'll have one as well kelly oppel
principal of bristol hall academy thank
you for joining us on the program this
morning and my apologies
again thank you but for those students
who might not have got the grades they
were hoping for today what can they do
going into the future well uh let's find
out from our next guest and that's uh
dave evans founder of
oco uh
there he is
no he isn't um i think uh dave is with
us hi dave
hello he is hi dave good morning to you
we've got you know um what is your
message to young people who don't get
these grades that we're here at you know
45 percent have got a and a star which
is all well and good for them but not
everybody gets it what should they do
they're not failures just because they
haven't got glittering results in their
exams are they
i mean i'm not sure i'm a
shining beacon of light here but i've
got two gcses one in maths which makes
sense the other in religious education
which i know nothing about
and if i'm able to be on sky news today
talking to uk about our new business
which helps bring social cohesion
then quite frankly anything's possible
okay so tell me about your new app i'm
not sure whether i pronounce it as oco
or oko
no
absolutely um
well it starts with what i wanted to
achieve um and what i wanted to achieve
was i mean it's a personal story to me
because i've experienced some diversity
as a young person myself
and so oko is there really i mean what
we wanted to achieve was cohesion parity
and an opportunity for all
um
then there's what is oco the non-sexy
way of describing oco is it's the
infrastructure that facilitates a
mentoring relationship between
people with the most potential by young
adults and people with the most
experience and knowledge to pass on
and effectively we are there to deliver
a direct injection of knowledge and
experience into the heart of our youth
with the idea that that will spur them
on and help them to
effectively avoid all the bumps and
crashing around i've had to uh go
through if that makes sense
but then there's the kind of the model
that sits behind it because we had to
build a model which uh delivered
exponential value to all
and so we've created a system where the
the young people the mentees they get it
for free but our customers are actually
the companies
and
the the companies get value out of it
because the program that sits behind oco
trains their staff to be great mentors
and nurtures the talent
and therefore all parties get something
fantastic out of it and we
i mean for me i think that the question
that we should all be asking at the
moment is how do we solve diversity and
inclusion
and whether it's racism it's sexism
whatever sort of inequality it is
it's about um helping everybody and
lifting everyone up to be prosperous at
the same time does that make sense it
most certainly does dave how do people
find your app
websites we are oco.com
um
we are just search we are oco and you'll
find us and encourage all young people i
mean you need to be 18 because we have
to provide i mean we can't
safeguarding is absolutely essential so
it's 18 plus but if you're a young adult
and you want a support function and this
is not to like the extreme cases like me
this is to anybody it's about just
helping us propel the country and i
think we
often
love that nick was on a minute ago
[Music]
and i'm pretty sure he did say that they
were going to adjust the system for the
record
but um
like you when you hear the government
talk about this stuff they talk about
how they're gonna do a three-year plan
or they're gonna put x amount of million
quid into it or whatever which is all
like nonsense to the people at home
um but the point for me is that we need
a direct injection of knowledge right
now and that's what oco was built on the
premise of sensational david it's good
to talk to you thanks very much for
taking the time appreciate it
yes see you later bye thanks a lot
um
the gcse results are coming up very
shortly indeed and we are at schools
around the country to see just how well
kids have been half a million kids
expecting their results a little bit
later on now 18 months ago a baby girl
called dalal was rushed across the
border from syria to turkey suffering
from burns all over her body after a
fire in a refugee camp since then sky's
alex crawford has followed her story
she's now been reunited with her family
and this is alex's report
the laos the miracle baby they never
thought would live
now performing for her delighted
audience
she will need years of reconstructed
surgery
the skin's growing over her eyes making
it hard for her to see
and her ears need entirely rebuilding
from her feet to her legs to her
amputated hands dalal will need medical
help for a long time
but she's made astonishing progress
since she was rushed to hospital at the
start of this year
she was covered in burns barely alive
and all on her own
her family's tent in idlib in syria went
up in flames the fire killed her elder
sister yasmine and left her with
terrible burns whilst her other four
siblings and parents somehow managed to
get out
she was transported to turkey as a
medical emergency and we followed her
fight to stay alive ever since her
battle stunned the turkish doctors and
prompted an outpouring of generosity
around the world
against all the odds in may she was well
enough to leave the hospital which had
been her and her father's home for more
than four
months it was an emotional moment for
the doctors who'd got so attached to her
and today is another milestone delaus
having her first outpatient laser
treatment
every step of this journey is full of
pain for the toddler
[Music]
she's anesthetized so they can work
trying to soften her tight and tender
scars
all this treatment's possible only after
some funds were provided by a family
foundation who saw our report
after the laser dalal is sleepy and sore
and very hungry and thirsty
she's learnt to cope with her injuries
and is managing remarkably well
but her father anxiously calls the rest
of the family still in syria to reassure
them she's okay
mother fatima and her siblings are in
idlib in a tent
this is the only way they've been able
to see each other since the fire they're
just one family amongst millions of
syrian refugees who fled their homes to
escape the war
but now they're finally leaving the camp
a british mothers raise thousands of
pounds to help pay for passports and
transport to reunite the family in
turkey
they leave behind thousands of other
children sheltering in camps on the
border
but before they depart syria without
knowing if they'll ever be able to
return they go to the graveyard
filled with the victims of war to say
alas goodbye to their daughter yasmin
who died in the fire
speak to her she beckons her other
daughters
i love you yasmin one says we're going
to see dad now
i wish you were with us says the other
waiting at the border on the turkish
side is dalal and her father abdel
fattah
and when the children see their father
and sister they can't hold back
they're delighted to be able to cuddle
dalal and immediately shower her with
affection
this is the first time they've been
together in six months
say hi to our friends their father tells
them
[Music]
fatima is heavily pregnant the journey
the stress the emotion of it all is
enormous
she can barely believe she's reached
safety and the family is one again
now begins the task of mother and
daughter getting to know each other
again
alex crawford sky news turkey
at least 65 people have been killed from
ongoing wildfires in northern algeria
joined by a member of the algerian red
crescent nafisa tumi hello to you uh
nafista thank you uh for joining us on
the program this morning um
give us a sense if you can about the
sort of devastating damage that this
these fires have been causing and what
what your work has included
the number of casualties of the white
fires declared on monday rose on
wednesday to 69
including more than 20 soldiers fighting
the fire
we deplore 600 families who have been
homeless and more than 1 000 injured
the algerian red cross and volunteers
are
bringing sanitary assistance and first
ads to the benefit of the first the five
victims
there's also distribution of food and
water brought by valentine's division
team moreover a carbon consisting on six
ambulances specialized doctors
for pharmaceutical products humanitarian
donation is being sent to assist the
victim of the fires
all the rescued family have been taken
in charge so rescue shelters have been
settled up and children psychological
supports have been organized since the
beginning of the fires
and
on the international level the algerian
red crescent has launched an appeal to
strengthen its humanitarian assistance
to its partners within the international
humanitarian movement
have you received any help from the
international community did you say
uh we
have launched an appeal and i we count
on the international solidarity of uh
red cross and red crescent movements and
then our partners
and of course the solidarity of the
algerian citizens
uh and of course also the algerian
authorities and what is what work are
you doing you are offering shelter to
those that have lost their homes i'm
guessing you're helping all ages
yes we are offering uh
shelters we are offering food and water
we also
distribute
masks
gloves because of this pandemic
and
we are trying to relieve people who are
in need
okay how long do you think that you will
have to
offer help and support i mean the damage
is extensive isn't it
yes really this situation is alarming
but we are making our best uh until
everything will be uh
better and uh
we hope you need to be better following
okay um keep well um doing fantastic
work there and hopefully you will get
increasing support from the
international community thank you
69 people now having lost their lives as
a result of those fires in algiers let's
find out what's happening as far as the
weather is concerned
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
good morning it's not looking too bad
across much of the uk and island for
today there will be some good amounts of
sunshine out there and largely dry
conditions but there will be blustery
showers affecting some areas as you can
see it will be across parts of the north
and west although currently most places
are starting off fine and dry this
morning lots of sunshine except there
are some isolated patches of mist and
fog and there's a cloudy zone that's
settled across parts of the stangle down
towards central and south western parts
of england with some patchy light rain
and drizzle
across western parts of ireland it is
also looking windy with some heavy
showers those showers will become more
widespread across ireland northern
ireland and the northwest of scotland
this afternoon
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
uh tamara is here um tomorrow we're
waiting to hear from the chancellor why
that's right because we've got the gdp
figures this morning and they cover the
second quarter of this year so april to
june when the economy reopened and they
show growth of four point eight percent
expected it is actually a bit below what
the bank of england thought at five
percent so it is good and i'm sure
richie cena will say that the economy is
bouncing back but we think that it's
slightly below the bank of england's
five percent and we think that's because
of the levels of self-isolation um which
we saw during that period particularly
after they put back freedom day from
june the 21st to july and because of the
growth of the delta variant but i think
rishi sunat will be saying it gives him
confidence that the uk economy can
bounce back quicker than was expected
for example last year will we get an
opportunity to ask him about his
relationship with the prime minister we
are uh one of our correspondents is
doing an interview with him shortly so i
believe we will be able to ask him about
um apparently his soaring popularity
with tory mps these kids are too young
to have done their gcses i believe they
are a primary school age yes okay um but
um see what he has to say about how we
get back to normal after nick gibbs said
that they were looking in the longer
term at resetting the grading system
yeah that was a that was a weird answer
from him just very quickly because we
will talk about it in more detail in
just a second but um he said that we are
looking um again at the structure of the
exams but not at the marks that's right
the context of next year's exams 2022
gcses and a levels has been consulted on
because students won't be examined on
everything as they were pre-pandemic
because they've obviously missed so much
school over the last couple of years
that is there's going to be
announcements on the content in the
autumn in terms of changing the whole
grading system potentially even moving a
levels to a numerical system that is for
ye the years to come but it's being
discussed